I sometimes talk about the dumb left on
the David Pakman show and buy the dumb
left I don't mean necessarily the
deliberately malicious people on the
left there are people who just focus on
bad ideas or they misunderstand a lot of
reality and they kind of become these
useful idiots unknowingly pushing the
agendas of people that they'd normally
disagree with there's also a dumb right
and this is important because there are
plenty of acutely genuinely malicious
people on the right but then there are
also simply dumb ideas and one of those
dumb ideas is the him to movement
hashtag him - and this has been floating
around for a little bit but it recently
got a big boost because of viral
facebook post that connected the him to
movement - Brett Kavanaugh was shared
about a hundred and fifty thousand times
and I want to talk about it and I will
mention in case it's not evident to you
hashtag him to is a sort of rebuttal or
counterpoint to hashtag me - which has
been mostly but not all women coming
forward about sexual assault and
harassment and rape that happened to
them mostly but not all at the hands of
male perpetrators so let's look at the
hem two movements poster or image or
graphic which says as long as women who
accuse men of sexual attacks are
believed without evidence or due process
no man is safe I'm not safe your husband
isn't safe your father isn't safe
hashtag him - your son isn't safe your
grandson isn't safe your male friends
aren't safe hashtag I stand with Brett
meaning Brett Kavanaugh and hashtag
confirmed Cavanaugh now I have so many
things to say about this I don't even
know where to start first of all the
right will very often create these sort
of counter movements to progressive
activism that looks to point out or end
or address inequalities or
discrimination or grievances against the
disadvantaged group by creating a group
exclusive for those that are usually the
perpetrators rather rather than the
victim so let me give you an example of
that cuz that's kind of a mouthful one
example would be oh there's an LGBT
Student Union at a college that's
exclusive they will say we'll show them
create a straight Student Union and we
won't allow LGBT people and it will be
all about defending the rights of
straight people first of all most of
those groups like most of those LGBT
student unions they don't actually ban
straight people from being members it's
for LGBT individuals and their allies
right some of them may be do ban
straight people and I think I'm probably
against that I think it defeats the
purpose but ok most of them don't
actually do that there's a Latino
Student Union okay
well we're making a white student union
no Hispanics allowed it's about white
pride it's about white community the
thing you have to understand is that if
the white student union and white pride
were being talked about in good faith
there really wouldn't be anything wrong
with it but then you look into these
groups and you realize that these
student unions and community groups
exist because there's been historical
oppression discrimination and other ring
of the minority groups and it's made
them feel the need for solidarity a
place where they can discuss issues with
allies and relate to their position in
society sort of in a comfortable manner
I'm not talking about a quote safe space
but I'm talking about a community space
that is based around issues relevant to
them in the United States white people
aren't oppressed straight people aren't
oppressed Christians aren't oppressed
and when you realize that you
immediately have to identify unless
you're willingly ignorant or
deliberately ignoring it or malicious
that these counter-movement groups the
white student union or the straight
student alliance or whatever straight
men's alliance they are being created in
bad faith and they often end a purpose
perpetrator I would say maybe
perpetuating is a better word the exact
kind of sentiment that causes people to
want the Hispanic Student Union or the
LGBT Student Union in the first place
and so that brings us to him - which is
what we're talking about now the hymn to
movement is arguing that at any time any
man could be the victim of false sexual
assault allegations they claim Brett
Kavanaugh is one of these people which
with every new accuser becomes hard and
harder to believe they want evidence and
they want due process the problem is
evidence and due process are
initial terms right the legal system
needs due process and should evaluate
evidence if they're going to dole out
prison sentences to people but the idea
that in casual colloquial life we should
presume that any woman who says I was
assaulted is a liar and that men are
actually the real victims is laughable
it is truly hilarious they will of
course point to individual cases of
false allegations of rape upset or
sexual assault we've covered those cases
Pat those instances are terrible if you
make false allegations about rape or
sexual assault you should be punished
and the law prescribes that punishment
there is no doubt about it but the
reality is that over all false
accusations about rape and sexual
assault are statistically rare we have a
country of three hundred and forty
million people even something that
statistically rare is still going to
happen but what happens much more often
is that when women do report a sexual
assault or rape very often the alleged
perpetrator is never punished so the
real problem is not an epidemic of men
who are being falsely accused and
punished for sexual assaults they didn't
commit again three hundred and forty
million people live here it happens we
should prevent it we should punish
people who make false allegations but
the real problems are the victims who
never come forward because of stigma and
because of the low punishment rate and
the fact that so many people mostly
women are sexually assaulted and for
years the right has blamed rape victims
by saying she shouldn't have been
drinking she shouldn't have been at a
party shouldn't some of the men worried
about false allegations listen to their
own advice because if they see
themselves as the victims
what if men didn't drink and go to
parties if you're home reading
Dostoyevsky while wearing you know a
beekeepers outfit or a hazmat suit or
whatever it is they think that the
female victims should be wearing to not
provoke somebody to rape them the
chances that they would be falsely
accused of rape would plummet
drastically and by the way there was
truly a rash of false accusations
against men of rape and sexual assault
why aren't men filing suits for
defamation
against their accusers make them pay if
they ruin your life with false
accusations there is legal recourse for
that barely ever happens I wonder why